مساء الخير،
بعد ان تناولنا في الحلقة الفارطة قراءة المفكّر فرج فودة،
للخلافة الراشدة في الإسلام في كتابه الحقيقة الغائبة،
وبيّنا كيف ان الخلفاء الراشدين ليسوا قدّيسين ولا انصاف ملائكة،
بل بشرا مثلنا تصارعوا وتقاتلوا من اجل السلطة والجاه،
نواصل هذا المساء تقديم قراءة فرج فودة للخلافة الأموية.
يفتتح فرج فودة ما سمّاة بقراءة جديدة في اوراق الأمويين بما يلي:
" للقارئ الآن وهو ينتقل معنا من عصر الراشدين إلى ما يليه،
أن يهيىء ذهنه للدعابة،
ووجدانه للأسى،
فحديث ما يلي الراشدين كله أسى مغلّف بالدعابة،
او دعابة مغلفة بالأسى،
اما المجون فأبوابه شتّى،
وأما الإستبداد فحدّث ولا حرج."
ثمّ يقصّ علينا فرج فودة ثلاث قصص قصيرة،
توضّح لنا النقلة النوعية من الخلافة الراشدة في عهد عمر بن الخطاب
إلى المُلك الوراثي على الشكل البيزنطي في عصر بني أميّة.
القصة الأولى: وقعت سنة 20 (عشرين) هجرية،
حيث وقف عمر بن الخطاب خطيبا على منبر الرسول في المدينة،
وتحدّث عن دور الرعية في إصلاح الحاكم،
فقاطعه أعرابي قائلا:
والله لو وجدنا فيك اعواجاجا لَقَوَّمناه بسيوفنا،
فانبسطت أسارير عمر،
وتوجه إلى الله حامدا وشاكرا،
وذكر كلمته المأثورة:
الحمد لله الذي جعل في رعية عمر،
من يُقوّمه بحد السيف اذا أخطأ.
القصّة الثانية: التي يذكرها السيوطي في كتابه تاريخ الخلفاء،
وقعت سنة 45 (خمس وأربعين) هجرية،
اي بعد ربع قرن فقط من القصة الأولى،
حيث نقل عن ابن عون انه قال:
كان رجل يقول لمعاوية:
والله لتستقيمن بنا يا معاوية،
أو لنُقومنّك، فيقول معاوية: بماذا؟
فيقول الرجل مازحا بسيف من خشب،
فيرد معاوية مبتسما: إذن نستقيم.
القصّة الثالثة: يذكرها السيوطي ايضا،
وقعت سنة 75 (خمس وسبعين) هجرية،
حيث خطب عبد الملك بن مروان، على منبر الرسول في المدينة،
بعد ان قتل عبد الله بن الزبير قائلا:
والله، لا يأمرني احد بتقوى الله بعد مقامي هذا إلا ضربت عنقه،
ثم نزل.
اراد فرج فودة من خلال رواية هذه القصص الثلاث،
ان يبين كيف تغيّر أسلوب الحكم من عمر بن الخطاب
إلى معاوية بن ابي سفيان مؤسس الخلافة الأموية
ثمّ إلى عبد الملك بن مروان أشهر رموز البيت المرواني،
الذي خلف البيت السفياني في الخلافة الأموية.
ويستنتج فرج فودة انه خلال نصف قرن فقط
مرّ أسلوب حكم المسلمين من العدل الحاسم في عهد عمر بن الخطاب
إلى الحسم الباسم في عهد معاوية بن ابي سفيان
ليصل إلى القهر الغاشم في عهد عبد الملك بن مروان.
يعود تأسيس الخلافة الأموية إلى معاوية بن ابي سفيان،
وذلك سنة 41 (إحدى وأربعين) هجرية،
بعد ان تنازل الحسن بن علي بن ابي طالب عن الحكم،
وبايعه مع أخيه الحسين في الكوفة،
وسُمي ذلك العام بعام الجماعة.
لكن مبايعة الحسن لمعاوية كانت بشروط،
يمكن تقسيمها إلى ثلاثة انواع:
أوّلا، شروط سياسية دينية متعلقة بالحكم،
وهي:
العمل بكتاب الله وسنة نبيه.
وأن تكون الخلافة من بعد وفاة معاوية  للحسن.
ثانيا، شروط أمنية:
وهي أن لا يُشتم علي بن ابي طالب،
ولا يذكر إلا بخير.
وأن لا يلاحق أحداً من أهل المدينة والحجاز والعراق من شيعة أبيه.
ثالثا، شروط مالية:
وهي أن لا يطالب معاوية أحداً من بني هاشم مما أصابوا أيام خلافة علي بن ابي طالب.
وأن يعطيه خراج دار أَبْجِرْدْ احدى أغنى المدن في بلاد فارس.
وان يمنحه كذلك كل ما في بيت مال المسلمين في الكوفة وقيمته خمسة ملايين درهم.
كان معاوية سخيّا مع الحسن بن علي لنيل البيعة منه،
لدرجة أنّه أرسل إليه صحيفة بيضاء مختومة كتب فيها:
أن اشترط في هذه الصحيفة ما شئت فهو لك.
ثمّ ضاعف معاوية في سنوات خلافته
عطاء الحسن والحسين من بيت مال المسلمين من خمسة آلاف درهم إلى مليون درهم سنوياً
وغض معاوية الطرف عمّا أخذه بنو هاشم من بيت مال المسلمين.
بعد ان اخمد كلّ الفتن واستقرّ له الحكم،
بدأ معاوية بن أبي سفيان في الإعداد لتوريث الحكم لإبنه يزيد،
فأرسله أولا قائدا للجيش المبعوث إلى غزو القسطنطينية،
ولم يكن هذا القرار عبثيا،
لأن معاوية بن ابي سفيان من كتبة الحديث،
ويعلم جيدا وجود حديث ينسب للرسول يقول فيه :
" أول جيش يغزو مدينة قيصر مغفور له".
ولإعطاء ابنه يزيد الذي عُرف عنه اللهو والمجون مزيدا من الشرعية الدينيّة،
جعله أميرا على الحج لبيت الله الحرام عند عودته من حصار القسطنطينية.
بعد وفاة الحسن بن علي بن ابي طالب مسموما سنة 49 (تسع وأربعين) أو 50 (خمسين) هجرية،
أصبح معاوية في حل من احد بنود معاهدة الصلح التي ابرمها مع الحسن،
والذي يقضي بتولّي الحسن الحكم بعد وفاته.
قيل الكثير حول من يقف وراء  تسميم الحسن بن علي،
ووجهت الشيعة التهمة لمعاوية ولابنه يزيد المستفيديْن الرئيسييْن من التخلّص من الحسن،
و لمعاوية بن ابي سفيان سوابق في التخلّص من خصومه بالسمّ،
مثلما هو الحال مع الأشتر النخعي أحد قتلة عثمان،
ووالي علي بن ابي طالب على مصر.
يقول ابن كثير في البداية و النهاية في الجزء السابع والصفحة 346:
"فلما سار الأشتر إلى مصر وإنتهى إلى القلزم إستقبله الخانسار
وهو مُقدِم على الخراج،
فقدم إليه طعاماً وسقاه شراباً من عسل فمات منه،
فلما بلغ ذلك معاوية وعمرو بن العاص وأهل الشام قالوا :
إن لله جنوداً من عسل".
سنة 61 (إحدى وستين) هجرية،
بعد وفاة الخليفة المؤسس للدولة الأموية معاوية بن ابي سفيان،
سيتولى بالتهديد والترغيب ابنه يزيد الخلافة،
لكنّه سيجد معارضة شديدة من أهل الحجاز،
وعلى رأسهم ابناء الصحابة؛
الحسين بن علي بن ابي طالب،
وعبد الله بن الزبير بن العوّام،
وعبد الله بن عمر بن الخطّاب،
وعبد الله بن العباس،
وعبد الرحمان بن أبي بكر الصدّيق.
فرج فوده سيولي اهمية كبرى لفترة حكم يزيد بن معاوية بن ابي سفيان،
لما شهدته من أحداث مأساوية هزّت الكيان الإسلامي.
لقد حكم يزيد بن معاوية ثلاث سنوات فقط،
من 61 (إحدى وستين) هجرية إلى 64 (أربع وستين) هجرية،
وخلال هذه المدّة الوجيزة ارتكب جرائم فظيعة،
ففي السنة الأُولى لحكمه قُتل الحسين بن علي بن ابي طالب،
وأهل بيته وأصحابه في كربلاء،
وقُطع رأس الحسين سبط الرسول،
وحُمل إلى قصر الإمارة بالكوفة لعبيد الله بن زياد،
الذي بدوره بعث به إلى يزيد بن معاوية في الشام مع نساء آل البيت كسبايا.
وفي السنة الثانية لحكمه،
زحف يزيد على المدينة بجيش قوامه ثلاثون الف مقاتل،
قاده مسلم بن عقبة،
وذلك بعد ان خلع اهلها بيعته.
وبعد ان هزمهم في موقعة الحَرّة،
اصدر اوامره لقائد جيشه باستباحة المدينة ثلاثة ايام،
وأوصاه بما يلي:
«ادعُ القوم ثلاثاً،
فإن أجابوك وإلّا فقاتلهم،
فإذا أُظهرت عليهم فأبحها ـ أي المدينةـ ثلاثاً،
فما فيها من مال أو دابة أو سلاح أو طعام فهو للجند،
فإذا مضت الثلاث فاكفف عن الناس».
قيل انه قُتل من اهل المدينة في موقعة الحرّة
حوالي اربعة آلاف وخمسمائة من أولاد وأحفاد المهاجرين والأنصار،
وفُضّت فيها بكارة الف بكر.
ويذكر الطبري في تاريخه،
انّه بعد موقعة الحرّة،
أنشد يزيد بن معاوية،
منتشيا،
وكان شاعرا مفوّها،
الأبيات التالية:
ليت أشياخي ببدر شهدوا
جزع الخزرج من وقع الأسل
قد قتلنا القوم من ساداتكم
وعدلنا ميل بدر فاعتدل
فأَهَلّوا واستهلّوا فرحا
ثم قالوا يا يزيد لا تشل
لست من خندف إن لم أنتقم
من بني أحمد ما كان فعل
ولعت هاشم بالملك فلا خبر جاء
ولا وحي نزل...
اذن من الواضح،
ان يزيد اعتبر ان موقعة الحرّة هي أخذ بثأر جده عتبة،
وأخي جده شيبة،
وخاله الوليد بن عتبة،
وغيرهم من بني أمية الذين قتلهم المسلمون في يوم بدر.
وفي السنة الثالثة والأخيرة لحكمه قبل موته في ظروف مسترابة،
بعث يزيد بجيشه إلى مكة،
لتأديب عبد  الله بن الزبير،
ابن الصحابي الزبير بن العوام،
وابن أسماء بنت ابي بكر الصديق،
الذي أعلن نفسه خليفة على المسلمين.
حاصر جيش يزيد مكة   في أوائل سنة 64هـ (اربعة وستين)،
وهو أول حصار لمكة في تاريخ الإسلام.
ظنّ عبد الله بن الزبير أن حرمة مكة ستمنع جيش يزيد من اقتحامها وتخريبها،
ولكن المهاجمين ضربوا بيت الله الحرام بالمنجنيق،
وتهدمت الكعبة واحترقت في الثالث من ربيع الأول سنة 64 هـ (اربعة وستين).
اقتحم جيش يزيد مكة ودار قتال عنيف بين الفريقين،
وفي تلك الأثناء جاء خبر موت الخليفة يزيد بن معاوية بن ابي سفيان،
فتوقّف القتال وعاد قائد جيش يزيد، الحُصين بن نُمير  بقواته إلى الشام،
وبقي عبد الله بن الزبير مسيطرا على مكة،
حيث سيعيد بناء الكعبة من جديد،
ويضيف إليها ستة أذرع ويجعل لها بابيْن.
بعد وفاة يزيد سيتولى الخلافة ابنه معاوية،
الملقّب بمعاوية الثاني،
ولكنه سيتنازل عن الحكم بعد أربعين يوما فقط،
ويُتوَفّىَ بالطاعون بعد ذلك بأيام قليلة.
بعد وفاة معاوية بن يزيد وشغور منصب الخلافة،
قدّمت عدّة أقاليم من بلاد المسلمين البيعة لعبد الله بن الزبير،
الذي كان قد اعلن نفسه خليفة للمسلمين في مكّة،
واصبح ابن الزبير يمثل تهديدا خطيرا على حكم بني امية،
خاصة بعد ان انقسم اهل الشام مركز ثقل الأمويين، إلى فريقين:
فريق قرر مبايعة ابن الزبير وهم القيسيون بزعامة الضحاك بن قيس،
وفريق آخر ظل على ولائه لبني أمية،
وهم اليمنيون في الشام بزعامة حسان بن مالك الكلبي.
استشعر كبار بني أميّة الخطر الذي يهدد حكمهم،
فقرروا عقد اجتماع تاريخي في الثالث من ذي القعدة سنة 64 (اربعة وستين) هجرية،
وضعوا فيه اتفاقا سُمي باتفاق الجابية،
ينصّ على مبايعة مروان بن الحكم خليفة للمسلمين،
وتكون ولاية الحكم بعده لخالد بن يزيد، ثم لعمرو بن سعيد بن العاص،
وبمقتضى هذا الإتفاق مرّت الخلافة الأموية من البيت السفياني إلى البيت المرواني.
حقق مروان بن الحكم في خلافته على قصرها عدة انجازات لبني امية،
فهزم جيش خصمه في الشام الضحّاك بن قيس الفهري،
وقتله في معركة تاريخية تعرف بمعركة "مرج راهط".
ثمّ زحف بجيشه بمعية ابنه عبد العزيز على مصر،
واستردّها من "عبد الله بن مجدم" الذي ولاه عبد الله بن الزبير عليها،
وعاد إلى الشام تاركا ابنه عبد العزيز واليا على مصر،
لكنه سيفشل في استرداد الحجاز من عبد الله بن الزبير،
وفي اخماد تمرّد الشيعة في الكوفة.
بعد ان استقرّت له الأمور،
سيعمل المروان بن الحكم على ضمان الخلافة بعد وفاته داخل البيت المرواني،
وسينقلب على اتفاق الجابية الذي عقده مع كبار بني أمية،
وسيتزوّج من ارملة يزيد،
ويوصي بالخلافة من بعده لإبنه عبد الملك بن مروان عوض ابنها خالد بن يزيد.
أصبح مروان بن الحكم دائم التحقير من شأن خالد بن يزيد،
فأشتكى خالد أمه  بذلك،
فتحينت الفرصة للانتقام منه،
وفي إحدى الليالي،
بينما كان  الخليفة مروان بن الحكم  مستغرقًا في نومه،
وضعت زوجته،
ارملة يزيد وسادة على وجهه،
ولم ترفعها حتى لفظ أنفاسه الأخيرة.
أراد ابنه عبد الملك بن مروان قتلها،
ولكن بني أمية نصحوه ألا يفعل ذلك،
حتى لا يُعيّره العرب بأن أباه قتلته امرأة.
بعد وفاة مروان بن الحكم،
سيتولّى الخلافة ابنه عبد الملك بن مروان،
الذي يعتبره الدكتور فرج فودة من أكبر رجال الدولة في التاريخ الإسلامي،
والمؤسس الثاني للخلافة الأموية بعد معاوية بن ابي سفيان،
فهو الذي استطاع اعادة توحيد الدولة بعد ان مزقتها الفتن والحروب،
وهو أول من قام بتعريب دواوين الدولة،
وإصدار اول عملة في تاريخ المسلمين وهي الدينار،
كما أشرف على تنقيط المصحف،
وشيد عدة مساجد من أهمها مسجد قبّة الصخرة في القدس،
وبُنيت في عهده مدن هامة منها مدينة تونس في افريقية،
ومدينة واسط في العراق.
كان عبد الملك بن مروان قبل تولّيه الخلافة ناسكا، تقيّا، فقيها،
لا يفارق كتاب الله أبدا،
وسُمي بحمامة المسجد لفرط مكوثه فيه.
يذكر الرواة،
أنّه يوم بايعه المسلمون على خلافتهم،
كان يقرأ القرآن،
فأطبق المُصحف وقال هذا "فراق بيني وبينك"،
أي فراق بين رجل الدين ورجل الدولة.
كان أمام عبد الملك بن مروان تحديان كبيران؛
اولهما استعادة مكة والحجاز والعراق من عبد الله بن زبير،
وثانيهما اخماد ثورات الشيعة والخوارج، وبسط نفوذه على كل العراق وبلاد فارس،
فالأمويون لم يتمكنوا من السيطرة على العراق كليا
منذ وفاة معاوية بن ابي سفيان.
تمكّن عبد الملك بن مروان في الخامس من ربيع الثاني سنة 65 (خمس وستين) هجرية،
من القضاء على ثورة التوابين،
وهم التوّابون لأنهم خذلوا الحسين؛
وأرادوا التكفير والتوبة عن خذلانهم إياه،
وهي أول انتفاضة شيعية، انطلقت من الكوفة ودعت للثأر لمقتل الحسين بن علي في كربلاء.
لكن ما إن أُخمدت ثورة التوابين،
حتى اندلعت ثورة المختار الثقفي تحت شعار يا لثارات الحسين،
وقد استطاع تتبع قتلة الحسين بن علي (في كربلاء) الواحد تلو الآخر،
وقتلهم جميعًا شر قِتلة،
واصطدم مع الأمويين في أكثر من معركة انتصر فيها جميعا.
لكن عبد الملك بن مروان سيعمل على عدم الإصطدام مع المختار الثقفي،
وبدهاء سيرقب المشهد السياسي في العراق عن بعد،
ويترك لمصعب بن الزبير،
شقيق عبد الله بن الزبير مهمّة القضاء على المختار الثقفي.
سيطر الزبيرون على بلاد الرافدين بعد ان تخلّصوا من المختار الثقفي،
ولكن جيشهم انهكته الحروب،
فاستغلّ عبد الملك بن مروان الفرصة،
وجهّز جيشا قويا من الشام قاده بنفسه،
وانتصر على مصعب بن الزبير وقتله في معركة دير الجاثليق سنة 72 هـ (اثنتين وسبعين)،
وبسط نفوذ بني أمية على العراق.
بعدها مباشرة،
سيجهّز عبد الملك بن مروان جيشا بقيادة الحجاج بن يوسف الثقفي،
ليرسله إلى الحجاز لإسترداد مكّة من عبد الله بن الزبير.
عبد الملك بن مروان لا يريد ان يتحمّل وزر الهجوم على بيت الله الحرام
كما فعل يزيد بن معاوية،
بل سيترك هذه المهمّة للحجاج بن يوسف الثقفي،
الذي كما ذكر الطبري في كتابه تاريخ الرسل والملوك،
انه حاصر مكّة حصارا دام لأكثر من ستة أشهر،
ثمّ نصب المنجنيق على الجبال المحيطة بمكّة المكرمة،
ورمى الكعبة وما حولها بالصخور الضخمة،
حتى احترقت الكعبة،
وهُدِّم جزء منها جرّاء قصفها بالمنجنيق.
ضاق الخناق على عبد الله بن الزبير وأهل مكّة،
واستسلم الآلاف منهم إلى جيش الحجاج بمن فيهم ابنيه حمزة وخبيب.
وفي 17من شهر جمادى الأول سنة 73 (ثلاث وسبعين) هجرية،
سيُقتل عبد الله بن الزبير،
وسيقطع الحجاج رأسه ويبعث به إلى عبد الملك بن مروان في الشام،
ويصلب جثته على احد أبواب مكة عدة أيام وقيل انه صلب معه كلب ميّت.
ثمّ سيكتب للخليفة عبد الملك بن مروان،
ليعلمه أنّ ابن الزبير قد زاد في مساحة الكعبة وأضاف لها بابًا ثانيا،
فأَمَره عبد الملك بن مروان أن يهدم ما زاده ابن الزبير،
وأن يغلق الباب الثاني الذي أضافه،
وان يجعل الكعبة كما كانت عليه حين بنتها قريش.
الحجاج بن يوسف الثقفي،
سيكون اليد الغاشمة لعبد الملك بن مروان طيلة فترة حكمه،
وسيولّيه على العراق ليقضي على الخوارج وثورة عبد الرحمن بن الأشعث.
عبد الملك بن مروان وهو على فراش الموت سيقول لابنائه:
"أكرموا الحجاج، فإنه الذي وطّأ لكمِ هذا الأمر"،
وبالفعل الحجاج بجبروته أضاف عقودا من الزمن لعمر الخلافة الأموية.
الفقيه الحسن البصري عاصر الحجاج،
ولأن الحجاج منع ذكر علي بن ابي طالب في المساجد،
كان الحسن البصري اذا ما اراد ان يروي حديثا للنبي،
رُوي عن علي بن ابي طالب، يقول:
رُوي عن أبي زينب، دون ان يذكر اسم علي،
ويقول الحسن البصري متحدّثا عن جبروت  الحجاج بن يوسف الثقفي:
"إن الحجاج عذاب الله،
فلا تدفعوا عذاب الله بأيديكم،
ولكن عليكم بالاستكانة والتضرع،
فإنه تعالى يقول:
(وَلَقَدْ أَخَذْنَاهُم بِالْعَذَابِ فَمَا اسْتَكَانُوا لِرَبِّهِمْ وَمَا يَتَضَرَّعُونَ)،
سورة المؤمنون آية 76.
الحجّاج بعد ان خدم عبد الملك بن مروان،
سيظلّ في خدمة ابنه الوليد،
إلى ان توفي سنة 95 (خمس وتسعين) هجرية،
حيث ترك وصيّة طلب فيها ان يُدفن سرا،
وأن يُخفي موضع قبره،
كي لا يتعرض للنبش.
توفي عبد الملك بن مروان سنة 86 هجرية،
بعد ان حكم لمدّة واحد وعشرين عاما،
تاركا إمبراطورية مترامية الأطراف وموحدة لابنه الوليد بن عبد الملك.
شهدت الدولة الأموية في عهد الوليد بن عبد الملك أوج قوتها وازدهارها،
فتوسعت شرقا وضمّت بلاد السند على يد محمد بن القاسم الثقفي،
و كذلك بلاد ما وراء النهر حتى حدود الصين على يد قتيبة بن مسلم،
أمّا غربا فقد تمكّنا موسى بن نصير وطارق بن زياد من السيطرة على بلاد الأندلس،
لكن امجادِهما العسكرية لم تمنع في ما بعد من عزلِهما واهانتِهما،
بعد ان اختصما حول غنائم الحرب في الأندلس وبلاد المغرب،
نهاية طارق بن زياد كانت مأساوية،
يُروى انه انهى حياته متسوّلا بين مساجد دمشق.
اهتم الوليد بن عبد الملك بالعمارة،
فشيّد المسجد الأموي في دمشق،
وأمر ابن عمه والي المدينة عمر بن عبد العزيز بتوسيع المسجد النبوي،
وامر ولاة الأمصار بحفر الآبار وتشييد الطرقات.
على المستوى الإجتماعي كذلك كانت له عدة انجازات؛
فهو أول من أنشأ المستشفيات في ديار الإسلام.
فقد أقام مستشفى للمجذومين والعميان في دمشق سنة 88 هـ،
على نفقة بيت مال المسلمين،
وقدم المعونة والمساعدة للمحتاجين واقام دور الرعاية.
وعُرف عن الوليد بن عبد الملك انه كان لحّانا (اي كثير الخطأ في التحدّث بالعربية)،
وهذا الأمر كان يؤرّق والده عبد الملك بن مروان،
يذكر السيوطي في كتاب تاريخ الخلفاء:
"قال روح بن زنباع :
دخلت يوما على عبد الملك بن مروان ـ و هو مهموم ـ فقال :
فكرت فيمن أوليه أمر العرب فلم أجده،
فقلت : أين أنت من الوليد ؟
قال : إنه لا يحسن النحو،
فسمع ذلك الوليد فقام من ساعته و جمع أصحاب النحو،
و جلس معهم في بيت ستة أشهر ثم خرج و هو أجهل مما كان،
فقال عبد الملك بن مروان : أما إنه قد أَعذر.
بعد وفاة الوليد بن عبد الملك سنة 96 هجرية،
سيتولّى الخلافة شقيقه سليمان بن عبد الملك،
والذي امتدت فترة خلافته سنتين وسبعة أشهر فقط،
عمل خلالها على التخلّص،
من الولاة الذي كانوا من بطانة الحجاج بن يوسف الثقفي،
ومن اهمهم قتيبة بن مسلم الباهلي ومحمد بن القاسم الثقفي،
ويعود ذلك إلى الدور الذي لعبه الحجاج في تحريض الوليد ابن عبد الملك
لخلع أخيه سليمان من ولاية العهد وجعلها لابنه.
سليمان بن عبد الملك سيستخلف بعده ابن عمّه عمر بن عبد العزيز،
الذي سيتولّى خلافة المسلمين سنة 99 (تسع وتسعين) هجرية،
والذي يعتبره التراث الإسلامي الخليفة الراشدي الخامس.
تميزت خلافة عمر بن عبد العزيز  بالعدلُ،
وردُّ المظالم التي ارتكبها أسلافه من بني أمية،
استمرت خلافته سنتين وخمسة أشهر وأربعة أيام فقط،
ومات مسموما سنة 101هـ( مائة وواحد) ،
ليتولى بعده  الخلافة يزيد بن عبد الملك.
يتحدّث الدكتور فرج فودة عن الخليفة الأموي التاسع يزيد بن عبد الملك،
فيقول، انّه أتى في أعقاب عمر بن العزيز،
الذي قيل عنه انه ملأ الدنيا عدلا طوال عامين،
فإذا بيزيد يأتي بعده لكي يملأها مغاني وشرابا ومجونا وخلاعة،
طوال اربعة أعوام،
ويذكر السيوطي،
انّه ما ان وُلي حتى أتى بأربعين فقيها فشهدوا له ما على الخليفة حساب ولا عذاب.
بدأت حياة الخليفة يزيد بن عبد الملك بعشق جارية اسمها سلاّمة،
وانتهت بعشق جارية أخرى اسمها حبّابة،
مات حسرة ولوعة على فراقها،
يروي ابن كثير ان يزيد كان مع جاريته حبابة في القصر يأكلان عنبا،
اذ رماها بحبة عنب وهي تضحك، فشرقت بها وماتت،
فأقام أياما هائما عند قبرها ثم رجع فما خرج من منزله حتى خرج بنعشه.
بعد وفاة يزيد بن عبد الملك سنة 105 هجرية،
سيتولّى شقيقه هشام بن عبد الملك الخلافة على أن تكون ولاية العهد للوليد بن يزيد بن عبد الملك.
أعاد هشام بن عبد الملك للخلافة الأموية هيبتها،
أشرك أولاده بالحروب،
وقلدهم قيادة جيوش المسلمين،
وكان شديد المراقبة للمال العام حتّى وُصف بالبخل،
كتب الجاحظ: كان هشام يقول: ضع الدرهم على الدرهم يكون مالاً.
وعُرف عن هشام حسن ادارته لدواوين الدولة،
وشهد له بجدارته أحد ألدّ اعداء الأمويين، وهو عبد الله بن علي بن العباس،
حيث قال:
جمعت دواوين بني مروان فلم أَرَ ديوانًا أصح ولا أصلح للعامة والسلطان من ديوان هشام.
لكن هشام بن عبد الملك سيرتكب جريمة فظيعة،
اعادت للوجدان الإسلامي جريمة مقتل الحسين بن علي في كربلاء
في عهد يزيد بن معاوية،
وهي جريمة مقتل زيد بن علي حفيد الحسين بن علي بن ابي طالب،
الذي ثار في الكوفة سنة 122 (مائة واثنتين وعشرين) هجرية،
فبعد دفنه،
أُخرجت جثته من قبره وصُلب على جذع شجرة أربعة سنوات، ثم أحرقت جثته.
توفي هشام بن عبد الملك سنة 125 هجرية،
وستكون وفاته بداية نهاية الخلافة الأموية،
يقول ابن كثير:
"لما مات هشام بن عبد الملك مات مُلْكُ بني أمية وتولى،
وأدبر أمر الجهاد في سبيل الله،
واضطرب أمرهم جدًّا،
وإن كانت تأخرتْ أيامهم بعهده،
نحوًا من سبع سنين،
ولكن في اختلاف وهيْج،
وما زالوا كذلك حتَّى خرجت عليهم بنو العباس فاستلبوهم نعمتهم ومُلكهم،
منهم خلقًا وسلبوهم الخلافة".
سيتولّى الخلافة بعد هشام بن عبد الملك ابن اخيه الوليد بن يزيد سنة واحدة،
من 125 (مائة وخمس وعشرين) هجرية إلى 126(مائة وست وعشرين) هجرية،
يتحدّث جلال الدين السيوطى عن فسق ومجون الوليد بن يزيد فيقول:
وكان فاسقًا، شريبًا للخمر، منتهكًا لحرمات الله،
أراد الحج ليشرب فوق ظهر الكعبة، فمقته الناس لفسقه،
وخرجوا عليه فقُتل في جمادى الآخرة سنة ست وعشرين.
سيتولّى بعده الخلافة ابن عمّه الذي انقلب عليه وهو يزيد بن الوليد،
ولكن خلافته ستستمرّ ستة أشهر فقط ليتولّى من بعده شقيقه إبراهيم لمدة سبعين يوما فقط،
ثم يُعزل على يد مروان بن محمد آخر خلفاء بني أمية والمعروف بمروان الحمار،
والذي سيقتله العباسيون بعد خمس سنوات سنة 132 هجرية،
وتنتهي بذلك الخلافة الأموية في المشرق
بعد ان حكمت على امتداد (92) اثنين وتسعين عاما.
يستنتج الدكتور فرج فودة من خلال قراءته للخلافة الأموية ما يلي:
ان عهد الدولة الأموية عهد مختلف كل الاختلاف عن عهد الراشدين،
وان الأمويين اخرجوا الإسلام من القبيلة إلى الإمبراطورية،
وان الخلافة الأموية على قصر عمرها قد حفلت برجال دولة عظام وهم؛
معاوية بن ابي سفيان،
وعبد الملك بن مروان،
والوليد بن عبد الملك،
وهشام بن عبد الملك،
وهم أربعة خلفاء صنعوا مجد بني أمية وحكموا سبعين عاما.
يقول الدكتور فرج فودة:
ويعود نجاح هؤلاء الخلفاء إلى فصلهم بين الدين والدولة عند قيامهم بأمانة الحكم،
وقد أحسنوا اختيار معاونيهم،
فكان منهم عمرو بن العاص،
والمغيرة بن شعبة،
وزياد بن ابيه،
ومسلم بن عقبة،
والحجاج بن يوسف الثقفي،
وهم جميعا من أهل الدهاء لا النقاء والسيف لا المصحف.
أتوقف عند هذا الحد،
لأعود لكم في الحلقة القادمة مع قراءة الدكتور فرج فودة للخلافة العباسية.
أشكركم  جزيل الشكر على المتابعة،
لا تنسوا الإشتراك في القناة،
وتفعيل الجرس ليصلكم كل جديد.
دمتم بخير وإلى اللقاء.